are you excited about the super well I
mean that is such an honor you know
that's a good word cuz it's it it's
become a holiday and you know that when
you go on and you're you know that
stupid moment before games were the two
announcers talk into the camera like
what do you think about today I don't
know what do you think about today and
you here's the things to watch for 120
million people I have that on their
television do you get nervous at all
still and it's a rush I mean when when
they're counting you down yeah and
they're going okay we got it in 30 and
then that's when your mind starts going
God don't screw this are you aware of
some of the bets about specifically
about how you announced the game then
there's like a like how many times
you'll say deflategate yeah and the
over-under is 2 point 5 I mean I could
literally take down Vegas myself you
could I have friends remember but
there's like 10 to 1 will I show up
clean-shaven if or with a beer what will
you do beard is it difficult for you to
negotiate a contract with Fox knowing
how many guys out there you know fine
sports casters want your job I've done
it now for 20 plus years right you know
it's not an easy job to do everybody's
good over here but when they're counting
you down for a hundred and twenty
million people to watch the network has
to know that you're not going to [ __ ] it
up
right and if and they have to trust you
that's what they're buying with me
they're buying somebody that they know
I'm not gonna make a dumb decision this
Sunday and say something that's gonna
get the network in a bunch of trouble
that's that's the premium and in that
unless you've sat in that seat you don't
know what that feels like right it is
tough I mean when you have that many
people listening and who are all experts
on their own well yeah and you've got to
know something you cannot [ __ ] up the
information no and I think the the
sports van in today's world is way more
intelligent than back even when I
started because of the internet because
of the betting because of fantasy
football they know people come up do
they know more about Richard probably
knows more about the Chiefs and the
Royals than I do do you study a lot
yeah when I say everyday yeah yeah you
have to read every day to keep up cuz
you know there's there's five stories a
day the problem is when you do a Super
Bowl there's an off week and you compile
so much information going into that game
I have this board that I make up you
start piling all this info on there and
by the end of two weeks you can't read
any of it
the staff that helps you with that you
know there's no time for that right and
and I need to do it myself like I need
to put the names and numbers and Heights
weights College I'll I have to do that
myself because if you call the wrong
that like you say oh that was number
blah blah doodad I guess yes or in oh
seven I did the Giants in the Super Bowl
and David Tyree makes this catch and if
there's one call I've made that I get
more trouble for it's this catch so it's
it's in the fourth quarter was it was an
unbelievable game it's the only time my
heart was about to jump out of my chest
doing a game cuz you go my god there's a
hundred million people it's the Patriots
were going for perfect season the Giants
they're from New York my god right it
gets no bigger and Eli Manning avoids
this sack heaves it downfield and David
Tyree kind of a third receiver makes his
catch he pins the ball on his helmet I
remember that and all these arms and
these bodies go to the ground and I'm up
there like first of all I thought
Manning was sack secondly I can barely
see who caught it whose helmet is it and
people were like you didn't give that
catch it's dunno it's do like you sit up
there if I start going oh my god and
unbelievable catch by David's it's
incomplete I beg your pardon it's that
you have to be sure when you do a Super
Bowl so when you're calling the game are
you watching a monitor of the game or
are you watching the field i watch the
field but the monitor is is is in front
of me to where if the picture
drastically changes I see it and I can
go to what they're showing I mean when
we do a Super Bowl I don't know the
total number but there's over 30 cameras
in the stadium that are so they can show
you just about anything so no
statistician or apps no yeah there is
yeah so I I do a game and I've got this
board I make up so I do all that myself
but then I've got a guy Dave swabbies
Staten Island zone who's over my
shoulder helping me with who made the
catch who made the tackle will do at the
Super Bowl you're announcing the game
and you got a P do you I mean there are
a lot of commercial but I've actually
called a touchdown in the NFL while
peeing is that true that's true
that's just learning out on my life it's
in my book how do you do that
well I had to go I drink I have to drink
a lot of water I drink a lot of coffee
which I know you guys been talking about
it but he hydrates you and it screws
with my voice yeah and so I'm drinking
water to kind of compensate for that
right so at the end of one of the halves
one time it was going taking forever
and I the bathroom was nowhere near the
booth so I was waiting and I'm dying and
I'm waiting and then a timeout and then
an injury and then and eventually I I
tell the guy next to me during a
30-second break which didn't allow me
time to go to the bathroom and come back
I said I got a pee and he hands me a
baaaad of little water bottle like this
I'm like not William Tell here so he
there's a girl in the booth who's a
stage manager I'm like whatever her name
was you're gonna have to leave and I'm
wearing a parka because it's cold and
they put a trash can with a trash bag in
it in front of me and I open up I unzip
and then I've got stage fright I have to
wait wait wait finally it starts and now
we're back and on the first play after
the timeout Sterling Sharpe was the last
game he ever played the NFL scores a
touchdown and I am literally peeing into
the trash now while I call the touch